you tweeted recently about older men
hitting on you
that obviously very attractive you're on
television you're going to get a lot of
attention but you don't like it when
older men hit on you little creep I'm 25
you know you're 25 yeah so what is your
age range that's acceptable for older
men I will give it
don't kill me maybe like a 40 that's not
like 39 40 is good for me you got a
cousin I'm under 40 yeah the only one
here that qualifies yeah okay well I was
hoping to be a little higher but anyway
uh except what you can okay
tasty such a great character and you
clearly you've inhabited this character
you've loved playing this character
what's your favorite line that you've
gotten to say it's tasty so my gosh I've
had a lot of fun stuff people really
love like you got those TV titties but
my favorite is the tasty red oh you got
to wrap them yes that is my favorite in
season one yeah yeah do you ever bust
that rap out I don't but for you what's
your the route
okay I'm sure it's might be a lot of
bleeping though is that okay you know we
just went through a whole thing with
Kumail so I left out the bad words yeah
that's true thank all right part of his
penis is missing what it's fine now all
right needs an explanation TV titties
okay let's hear it
okay can I get some clapping yeah a
little slower slower
hey call me tasty has my feed delicious
nutritious I can put in its and dishes
you want to mix it on it [ __ ] please
use the net you got fat best be Brad
[Applause]
we know children's parties for you